[Música]
no hay que desperdiciar una buena crisis
esa frase se la estoy robando no a
winston churchill a quien se las suelen
atribuir winston churchill fue el primer
ministro de inglaterra en la etapa de la
segunda guerra mundial y la etapa
posguerra y de pronto el medio obvio que
la frase se le atribuye a él pero en
realidad no hay ningún registro
histórico escrito de que él haya sido el
origen de la frase entonces busquemos
otra que tal que ellos y salares esto es
cultura pop
estos game of thrones y este es looking
erc es el antagonista de la serie
entonces de pronto oído decir que ese
salario el caos es una escalera suena
como
somos escépticos hacia esto de pronto
está hablando de aprovecharse del caos
para surgir y para su venganza personal
pero repensemos a esto de pronto
aprovecharse de una crisis no es
necesariamente malo de pronto la gente
que se aprovecha de una crisis ahora es
la gente que va a crear compañías y que
va a crear empleos y que nos va a ayudar
a salir y superar la crisis busquemos
otra que tal esta no es el más fuerte el
que sobrevive es el que mejor se adapta
y ajusta al ecosistema en que se
encuentra y tal vez agregado un poquito
es el que más rápido se puede ajustar al
ecosistema en que 50 estoy parafraseando
a charles darwin y pronto está la frase
que nos calza mejor las personas que
logren adaptarse más rápidamente a las
nuevas situaciones son los que salen
ganando son las que las aprovechan y de
nuevo aprovecharlas no es necesariamente
malo aprovecharlos puede ser la
respuesta para salir de la crisis
hay un ejemplo que me encanta de la
última crisis y entonces veamos un
poquito del contexto de que él fue lo
que sucedió en 2008-2009 sucedió lo que
todavía conocemos como la gran recesión
y pronto esa apreciación tal vez es
pequeña comparada a la potencial
recesión oa la real recesión en la que
estamos en este momento
yo no estaba muy consciente de qué está
pasando en 2008 y 2009
pero más de 34 millones de personas
perdieron su trabajo y un poquito de
historia y una versión super
simplificada de lo que pasó
en 2008-2009 experto a una burbuja de
riego state de bienes raíces en eeuu
en resumen y por resumen los bancos y
los inversionistas prestaron más dinero
del que realmente deberían prestar y
apostando a que las personas no iban a
dejar de pagar sus hipotecas pero en
realidad estos préstamos eran préstamos
de muy mala calidad préstamos a familias
y personas que no realmente tenían la
capacidad de pagarlos y cuando un número
suficiente de préstamos
o de hipotecas no se pagaron el sistema
financiero de eeuu se cayó como una con
una casa de cartas
de nuevo es una versión super resumida
pero al final de cuentas es importante
para entender el contexto de esta
historia
la gente no puede pagar sus hipotecas
los bancos quebraron antes se quedó sin
trabajo y por tanto menos gente pudo
pagar sus hipotecas y esto incluso no lo
sé
o se volvió como una bola de nieve en
medio de esta crisis
tres jóvenes emprendedores en san
francisco
se les ocurrió la idea de alquilar un
colchón inflable en su sala de ser un
colchón inflable en la sala de la casa y
lo tiraban para que la gente se queda
que estaban tratando de probar estaba
tratando de probar si la gente estaría
dispuesta a quedarse en el colchón
inflable de un extraño y si estuvieran y
si estaban dispuestos a pagar por esto
de pronto este negocio esta idea y
calzaba entre dos entre dos cosas que ya
existían y que ya sabíamos que
funcionaban un lado de los hoteles donde
todos pagamos por quedarnos y por otro
lado una compañía que se llamaba
couchsurfing y que era un sistema o es
un sistema que todo existe para
mochileros o gente que está de viaje
para quedarse en las casas de extraños
entonces el filtro que hay en cup
surfing es que uno conecta con otras
personas en el sitio web entiende si
están dispuestos a recibirlo en su casa
las personas de su casa ven a su vez que
la persona que viene a quedarse no es un
extraño
esta es una transacción que suele
suceder sin pagar pero al final de
cuentas prueba este concepto la gente
está dispuesta a recibir a gente en su
casa en este caso es por conocer
extranjeros por conocer a gente que está
de paso
pero qué tal si hay algo en el medio de
estas dos cosas qué tal si podemos de
pronto cobrar por ese espacio en la casa
esta idea de un colchón inflable se
llama server and breakfast y hoy la
conocemos como ir bien
y entonces hoy en día es una compañía
gigante y tal vez a ustedes tal vez la
mayoría ustedes ya la conozcan y se han
quedado en un ir bien pero a veces
cuesta entender la dimensión de estas
compañías ir viendo y tiene 6 mil 300
empleados o tenía 6 mil 500 empleados
antes de que empezara el pandemia de
coronavirus y cerró 2019 entre 3.000 y
4.000 millones de dólares de ventas que
son más de 500 mil dólares de ventas por
cada empleado
para ponerlo más en perspectiva
la valoración que los inversionistas le
dieron ayer bien bien 2018
era la mitad del producto interno bruto
de costa rica entonces esta compañía
este colchón inflable en una sala y
estos 6 mil 300 empleados valen la mitad
de la mitad de nuestro país para los
inversionistas y no es descabellado ir
bien vino a cambiar el mundo en
muchísimas de muchísimas formas para
bien y para mal no deja de estar exento
pero por qué porque el bien vi tuvo
tanto éxito porque fue una compañía
creada durante una crisis que aprovechó
la situación de la crisis para resolver
problemas porque porque por un lado
teníamos a gente que no podía pagar las
hipotecas de sus casas que estaba
buscando cómo generar ingresos
adicionales y que de pronto tenía
espacios ociosos desde un sillón hasta
un cuarto adicional hasta un colchón
inflable y por el otro lado gente que
necesitaba viajar o quería viajar pero
no quería pagar los precios de los
hoteles porque estábamos en media crisis
entonces esta compañía conectó dos cosas
muy conscientemente dos cosas están
sucediendo
en la vida real en el momento desde el
contexto sociocultural y económico del
momento y las aprovecha de nuevo no deja
de estar
bien bien no deja de estar envuelto en
controversia por ejemplo en ciudades
donde hoy en día ha sido muy exitoso el
valor de los alquileres y el valor de
las de las propiedades se ha disparado
muchísimo porque de pronto las casas se
pueden monetizar de otras maneras a
parte de nada más vivir que pues no
monetizar las casas en los hoteles han
sufrido muchísimo porque piensen en
cuánto cuesta mantener un cuarto
adicional en mi propia casa y limpiarlo
cuando viene alguien versus mantener y
ccoo pues construir primero y mantener
una habitación de motel y tal vez los
dueños de hoteles no aprecien lo que voy
a decir pero que cuál de las dos es
mejor definitivamente hay una razón por
la que no se quede en hotel siguiéndome
un día de negocios o si quieren una
experiencia de lujo entonces un hotel es
el destino correcto pero qué tal si
quiero conocer la cultura del lugar si
quiero quedarme en una familia conocer a
una familia local quiero probar la
comida local quiero conversar con ellos
de pronto también dice una mejor opción
de pronto es una mejor opción aprovechar
estos recursos ociosos estas
habitaciones libres estas casas
desocupadas
y construir un nuevo hotel con
habitaciones que sólo se ocupan cuando
la gente viene
conozco no conozcan ir bien vi en mí
hay un ejemplo que me encanta que es ese
la curva de opción este gráfico acá es
una curva de adopción
usamos otro ejemplo usamos una compañía
como instagram instagram salió en 2010
y yo publiqué mi primera foto en
instagram por ahí de 2011 es decir me
gusta pensar que fui uno de los primeros
en adoptar
instagram no suficientemente rápido para
agarrar el nombre el hand all que
querían pero me parece que final los
primeros la mayoría de la gente adoptó
instagram
más o menos en los últimos 3 4 ó 5 años
esto es la mayoría y hay un bloque de
gente que aún no lo adoptado que son los
tardíos pero este curva de opción aplica
para cualquier producto para cualquier
tecnología que tiene cierto éxito de
pronto veamos trabajar desde la casa
cuántas empresas tenían alguna modalidad
de trabajo desde la casa hace varios
años cuántas empresas habían
implementado sistemas para hacerlo
eficiente para tener videollamadas
suficientes y estaban dispuestas a
trabajar en este sistema esos fueron los
primeros
a la mayoría y a los tardíos les toca
hacer este cambio a la fuerza
y de pronto ser uno de los primeros tuvo
sus ventajas y este cambio fue menos
drástico pero antes de hablar de tres
tipos de empresas o incluso de tres
tipos de personas en estas curvas de
adopción hay una cuarta persona y hay
una cuarta persona que es quien empieza
la curva de adopción y esa persona es un
unicornio es un [ __ ] raro que se llama
emprendedor y que hace el emprendedor
después es la persona que detecta este
status quo que detecta estos problemas
que detectan estas oportunidades y
encuentra soluciones el trabajo de
emprendedores tienen cuentas es resolver
problemas el problema global o el
problema de producto o el problema de
servicio que su compañía resuelve y por
supuesto todos los problemas internos
que suceden en la compañía
pero el mundo se acaba inventar un
montón de problemas ahora no podemos
acercarnos a la gente distanciamiento
social de pronto hay decenas de millones
de personas desempleadas de pronto no
podemos salir de nuestro país no podemos
volar entonces cuál es él cuáles son las
soluciones para estos nuevos problemas
que el mundo se acaba de inventar
para mí las soluciones están en la
historia de ir bien vi que es en
repensar recursos ociosos tenemos tantos
recursos ociosos que no optimizamos
cuando nos toca apretarnos la faja en el
en el trabajo o en la casa o con
nuestros ingresos lo primero que hacemos
es evitar el desperdicio y entonces y
qué cosas estamos desperdiciando hay
unos empleos ninguno está en el
inventario son ejemplos de problemas que
ya hay compañías que están tratando
trabajando en solucionarlos
un recurso clásico son los parqueos los
parqueos en medio de la ciudad son
literalmente un lote vacío donde carlos
se parquean en ciudades más densas
en eeuu donde donde empezó este
movimiento o este tipo de empresas que
están solucionando esto el problema que
encontraron es bueno resulta que la
gente vive en su edificio departamentos
de pronto tiene un espacio de parqueo
asignado pero cuando se va el parqueo
queda libre y vaya a pagar parqueo en
otro lado en su oficina qué tal si ese
parqueo se puede reutilizar se puede
alquilar y entonces la gente que viene a
la ciudad y necesita dónde parquear si
no tiene que ir a pagar no tiene que ir
a pagar por una estructura por un por un
lote de parqueo diseñado específicamente
para eso sino que aprovecha el recurso
ocioso de un parqueo libre que no va a
estar ocupado durante el día hay un
montón de compañías tratan de resolver
este problema
qué tal con el carro resulta que el
carro es un recurso que usamos tal vez
tres o cuatro horas al día y las otras
20 horas está completamente desocupado
qué tal si podemos alquilar el carro a
otras personas para que lo usen y lo
aprovechen hay que solucionar problemas
hay que solucionar seguridad hay que
solucionar quién se encarga si el carro
choca pero el que soluciona este
problema empieza aprovechar este recurso
ocioso que todos tenemos pues no que
todos tenemos pero que la gente tiene y
empieza a monetizar lo distinto y
entonces el carro de pronto no se
convierte en un gasto se convierte en un
recurso que se paga solo
otro ejemplo de mis favoritos sí y
alejándonos un poco de la tecnología
las cocinas resulta que ahora todos
tenemos que trabajar desde la casa
la gente en su casa no quiere gastar en
un restaurante pero tal vez no tenga
tiempo de cocinar porque está trabajando
y quiere comer sano cuál es la respuesta
es bueno resulta que
se ha abierto legislación en varios
países que permite a la gente establecer
cocinas caseras y que es una cocina
casera es una operación como un
restaurante pero donde está prohibido
contratar gente porque en ese momento
pasa a modalidad restaurante sino que es
una operación individual o familiar
donde la gente cocina dentro de su casa
y le puede vender comida a sus vecinos y
esto está regulado y permitido dentro
del país
y de nuevo está aprovechando este récord
socios o de pronto alguien desempleado o
alguien alguien que cocina muy bien que
tiene su cocina en desuso y se lo vende
a estas personas que están trabajando de
la casa es una éxito es un es una
compañía es un sistema creado ideal en
la situación de crisis en la que estamos
abriendo
el último ejemplo es una compañía que se
llama tasas gravity que lo que ha hecho
es que ha conectado a gente que tiene
habilidades
caseras con gente que no las tiene yo
soy terrible taladrando y jamás
instalaría ante él en la pared de mi
casa bueno qué tal se puede contratar un
vecino que lo sabe hacer todas estas
bright conecta estas dos personas con un
sistema de rating con un sistema de
acuerdo de pago y demás y demás
consideraciones que hay que tener para
atraer a un extraño a la casa pero que
instala el tele entonces esta persona
que tiene este talento y estas
herramientas en la casa de pronto está
aprovechando este recurso ocioso también
el recurso ocioso más evidente con el
que nos hemos topado es nuestro propio
cerebro
cuántos cerebros desocupados hay en el
mundo en este momento en cuántos
cerebros hay en el mundo viendo netflix
que no establecen mejor uso el mejor uso
del cerebro que podemos hacer con este
recurso ocioso que podemos hacer para
solucionar y conectar
recursos ociosos con gente que los
necesita aprovechar porque porque el
mundo se acaba de inventar mil y un
problemas nuevos pero a la vez dejó de
lado un montón millones probablemente
incontables recursos ociosos que podemos
hacer para conectar estos dos que nos
está haciendo y si supiera la respuesta
a esto y si supiera una nueva manera de
conectar estas dos cosas probablemente
estaría trabando en eso no sé cuál es
pero es no es el objetivo esta charla el
objetivo es echarles que ustedes sean
las personas que encuentran estas
soluciones sean las personas que se
aprovechen de la crisis' porque son
estas ideas las que pueden sacarnos
adelante porque no tenemos que
desperdiciar una buena crisis
[Música]